This beautiful tuck lace stitch
pattern can be worked on any machine.
Tuck lace is a combination of tuck
and needles out of work to create open,
lace-like stitch patterns
without transferring stitches.
We'll discuss manual,
automatic patterning machines,
both punch card and electronics,
and explore both Brother and Silver/Singer/
Studio machines in this video.
Now, please don't skip the manual
machines demo at the beginning.
It'll go a long way towards your
understanding how this
stitch pattern is created.
Tuck
on a manual machine like a Taitexma 160 or
an LK150 is actually worked as
a pull-up stitch, using using hold.
Needles to tuck are pulled all the way out
and the carriage is set to hold position.
It's the combination of the needle
positions and the hold setting
that carries the working yarn
over the needles in hold.
After three rows, all needles
are knit, securing the tucks.
The tucking needles are then alternated,
creating this interesting
beautiful stitch pattern.
For all machines,
here is the needle set up.
One needle in work and two needles out
of work across the bed, leaving two
needles on each side in working position.
This will secure the edge
stitches and create a selvedge.
No tucks are formed on these end needles.
On a manual machine,
cast on and hang a cast on comb
or use a cast on rag and weights.
Weight is important
for this stitch pattern.
Let's identify the sets of needles
that will tuck as red and yellow.
Start by pulling the red needles all
the way out and set your carriage
to hold in both directions.
On this machine, put the levers to H.
On an LK150, put the Russell
levers in this position.
Tuck in both directions for three rows.
Cancel hold and knit one row across
all the needles, securing the tucks.
Next, pull the yellow
needles all the way out.
Reset your carriage to hold in both
directions and knit three rows.
Notice that you are tucking
over the opposite needles.
Cancel hold and knit one row.
That's it.
It looks complicated, but these
eight rows are the entire pattern.
Now, if you lose track of red and yellow
needles, watch your row counter.
Row counter zero, one, and two,
hold the red needles.
Row counter three, cancel hold.
Row counters four, five, and six,
hold the yellow needles.
Row counter seven, cancel hold.
Create yourself a little cheat
sheet to help keep track.
Another trick for keeping track
is to examine the knitting.
Here I've just knit the closing
row and all the needles have knit.
I can see the column of stitches here
that were knit and the tuck stitches here.
This tells me that these are the needles
to pull for the next set of tucks.
If you have a punch card or electronic
machine, the stitch
pattern looks like this.
Instead of the hold setting,
like on a manual machine, we'll let the
automatic paterning select needles for us.
On these machines,
needles in working position will tuck
and needles in middle position will knit.
On Brother machines, this is obvious.
On Silver reed, this needle selection
happens behind the scenes
and it isn't as clear.
This stitch pattern is
an eight-row repeat.
The hardest part is determining what
needles should be in work and what
needles should be out of work.
Remember, by default,
a punch card or electronic stitch pattern
will be aligned to the
center of the machine.
So you need to determine
what zero is on your machine.
For this stitch pattern, needle left one,
the first needle to the left
of zero needs to be in work.
The needle arrangement will
then be set up from there.
One needle in work, two needles
completely out of work across the bed.
To create a selvedge will keep
two needles in work on the edges.
Let's stop here for a minute.
The pattern asks for the first needle
to the left of zero to be in work.
Now, maybe you've tried tuck lace before
and got stuck because you didn't know
what needle should be in and out of work.
In the Brother Stitch World books,
the diagrams for tuck lace look like this.
The O indicates the needles out of work.
But where is zero?
It's never been clear to me.
Plus, I discovered that my needle number
strip was not aligned to zero,
so I was putting the wrong needles out
of work when I first
tried this stitch pattern.
Brother machines preselect needles,
and it's easy to dry knit this stitch
pattern and observe
which needles are tucking.
The needles that are tucking are put
in B position or working position.
Needles that are going to knit
are put in D or middle position.
I used KC2 for this pattern
and ran my carriage
across to see which needles were tucking.
And then set up my needle alignment.
One in, two out, one in,
two out, all the way across.
For Silver Singer machines,
one way to determine where your zero is is
to knit the stitch pattern
with all needles in work.
Cast on with waste yarn and set your
machine to tuck and knit
the first row of the pattern.
You'll immediately be able
to see which needles are tucking.
Since your machine automatically centers
the stitch pattern on the needle bed,
the first tuck needle next
to your zero will be tucked.
Based If on that selection, put
the rest of the needle arrangement
in place, one needle in, two needles out.
One needle in, two needles out.
For any automatic patterning machine,
once you've established the correct needle
arrangement, make sure you put those two
needles into working position as you knit.
Your machine will want to tuck one
of those needles on the tuck rows.
Pull them out each time so they knit
and you have a nice edge
to use for your garment.
No matter what machine you use,
using weights and blocking are key
to this openwork stitch pattern.
I suggest you let your knitting rest
and then use blocking wires
to secure the strands.